this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base a subscription website
where you can download thousands of
medical images and videos to use in
lectures courses presentations
professional training and more for more
information click on the link in the
description
your urinary tract includes the kidneys
ureters
bladder
and urethra
your kidneys make urine which flows
through the ureters to your bladder
your bladder expands to store urine
until you're ready to urinate
muscles called sphincters contract to
hold urine in your bladder
when you urinate the sphincters relax
this allows urine to pass out of your
body through your urethra
strong pelvic floor muscles support your
bladder and other organs so they can
work properly
stress urinary incontinence means urine
leaks by accident when movement puts
sudden pressure on your bladder
it can happen when you cough laugh
sneeze or exercise
urine can leak if your sphincters or
pelvic floor muscles have become weak
things that can weaken these muscles
include childbirth obesity
aging and pelvic surgery
to find out more about stress urinary
incontinence talk to your healthcare
provider